I get hello welcome to YouTube gaming at
PAX Prime I'm your host Don E&Y from
GameSpot calm and we're back back but
the kind of funny guys here what's going
on hey Jim Gettys we're here yeah Scarpa
the only ones clapping for us so no mic
from game whispers that bad yeah you can
hear them these guys on the bench over
there not sold they don't know us yet
and so we're here to announce that I'm
replacing Colin Moriarty on Kyle money
Oh a real Irish person [ __ ] yeah
well you know my roots
get off the fence Moriarty I was looking
forward to getting you up on stage and
playing some Malcolm's right yeah if you
needed another reason to hate Konami ah
they have not shown up here like they
said they would because apparently the
traffic in Seattle is pretty bad yeah
have some runners downstairs who might
be able to get it boom oh wow okay well
see no big deal if you're already
watching this on YouTube after
everything's done go to youtube.com
slash kind of funny games we've had a
week of exclusive Metal Gear Let's Plays
up where I played really well and no
one's been me you in the comments great
has it been changed your wrist for the
entire week no you remember that
remember what Grand Theft Auto Ford
remember that NDA rockstar had yeah I
had to be in a sealed container within
like eye contact of somebody at all
times and if you leaked footage they'd
sue you a million dollars
1 million dollars 1 million we were at
the review event where like we were
playing and stuff like okay don't talk
about it don't you can only tweet this
out and like then there were stories a
bit like all right it's leaking it's out
in greenness areas whatever you know
enemy is a guy right whatever yeah so
last week was it you spend all week
basically playing the game yeah yeah
it's any good it's fantastic yeah yeah
for sure it's the best Metal Gear game
play they've ever had in Metal Gear
that's like an insane thing to say I
noticed I I know that that's a crazy
thing to say like I'm aware as I was
saying it that it was insane but it's
true like for me I've always described
myself as a story [ __ ] right like I'm
playing games for the story and this was
the flip of that where the story is
alright it's fine don't get me wrong
it's pulling me through I want to know
what's happening obviously there's a lot
of questions already just from trailers
but really what was bringing me back
night after night day after day still
now right I'm like 65 hours into the
I still want to keep playing it for I
want to take out this outpost and I want
to get this emblem and I want to kidnap
that person to make my R&D structure
better so I can make another strut and
mother base so I can develop this and
it's just it's like that whole it's a
gameplay loop and kick it away from
which is crazy because the Metal Gear
franchise has always been a kind of a
okay I'm gonna play through this and
then you know what actually gonna play
through it again but I like either a new
game plus it or like or try something
else right the idea that there's this
like like open world for that series is
totally totally alright yeah and it was
fun
this week I went back to LA and I got to
sit down with Kojima and talk to him
about it right and that was one of his
questions up to for me cuz he was
interviewing me which was super weird he
was interviewing me and he asked me like
you know but he did how do you the
bandages back on again no there's no
bandages this time he asked me always
like you know how does it feel like the
fact that you know what Metal Gear has
been homier and now it's open does it
work and it totally works and that's the
interesting thing like I've been
answering comments the best I can on
Twitter right and people are asking me
like what are the difficulty settings
how many save files and it's like there
are none there's one you know I mean
yeah you just play in this world and
it's set up as it is and then once
you've beaten the game you unlock harder
versions of the missions you already did
where it's like okay now you go in and
you have no equipment now you go in if
they see you it's over now I mean
they're increasing the difficulty that
way which is very fascinating okay let's
go down as murderers row in terms of
Metal Gear fandom have you played all
the games in the bath yeah come on
tonight I haven't played all of them I
played majority of them I stayed away
from peace Walker
okay and uh at the portable ops and all
those others all right well the fact
that you're planting dough's is part
yeah or well I'm very familiar with
mammal game okay every numbered game oh
you found one like you played forty five
percent of a Metal Gear the demo I
finished it to be perfectly honest no I
mean that's the thing I'm excited about
this game and I really do actually want
to play it but it's it's kind of sad
that this is getting my first like
entree into the Metal Gear series man
you guys so confused oh my god well I
was down there with Greg when he was
playing through some of it in LA and we
sat at dinner I'm like just give me like
the rod over catch me up real quick he
goes okay so there's like three snakes
and there's like this I just my mind
just went white for a second and I came
and I was like I'm just gonna jump in
and just see so there's three snakes
might be like the best opening line yeah
any like I feel that peace walker ground
zeroes and now five have all learned
from previous mistakes or things that
they used to get knocked for right
whereas like peace walker I really felt
you could just jump into United mean
like sure it'd be helpful if you knew
everything about Big Boss verse boss
yadda yadda yadda maybe not they tell
you what's happening and similar with
ground zeroes even though it's a little
bit murkier but for sure
five opens up and if you haven't played
any other Metal Gear like you're gonna
be disoriented in the beginning because
they want you to be disoriented they
even isn't you know playing as me you're
like what the hell is happening I don't
understand what's going on but then like
mission between mission what art I guess
two and three is when they are like
here's how this relates to ground zeroes
and who you are and what's inside ok now
I'm on track even if I didn't know
anything but here's like even Metal Gear
Solid 1 felt that way you know like yeah
yeah and what I've seen a five it kind
of seems like that leaks from the
trailers and stuff even as a huge burger
fan I don't know what's going on but no
one does male against something - oh
yeah same thing like the first three
hours are like totally different game
yeah what but that's my questions be you
guys like you guys are all diehard Metal
Gear fans how much Metal Gear do you
need for this one this for five to
actually make sense
I'm semblance of sense I don't think you
need anything yeah no I mean it's you're
gonna be it's good there is going to be
points of confusion but again he's he's
trying to confuse me he's trying to fuse
anyone who knows anything about Metal
Gear so do you think as a person who's
never played a Metal Gear Frank like
Syria game it at all this is the one to
start with or do I need to go back it's
the same thing as always I would always
encourage you to go back but I would say
I mean for to understand what's
happening here and be more like go back
to Peace Walker because that's an easier
entry point it's 12 hours you're done
because that's the thing for me I
watched the gameplay and I'm like this
the core mechanics just the sneaking
around and stealth yeah the base
building on stuff looks awesome it just
looks super fun but then I get to the
story elements and I'm like I know this
is deep but to me no sense so if you
went in on any of the other ones you'd
have the same confusion with the stories
but the gameplay you'd also be confused
about because if you go back and play
those games they're not like picking off
normal like third-person action game
they have weird idiosyncrasies I think
four is four
yeah when it first started being a
little bit more modern and peace walker
as well where you could pick that up and
play it but once that was when they did
like the action can get back with a big
job like inventory on the thumbsticks
and all this the combining start was
like dad played dad Greg that's the one
you could have played dead end I think
five is gonna be a really good entry
point for you because it is more
gameplay focus than story yeah but we're
hearing yes and the thing with the story
is it's like it makes sense and does it
make sense simultaneously no matter what
every character has four names you know
there's all right and stuff that you
don't really know what's going on yeah
but it's like it almost doesn't matter
because each game introduces you to the
characters you need to know and gives
you their story sometimes we get little
glimpses of other people and it's like
oh this guy relates to this guy this way
but it's like they'll tell you that in
one you're playing okay all right those
phantom pain have the same level of like
crazy antagonists no that was a big
surprise for me okay boss battles and
like a team of bosses they don't really
exist laughs okay this game like you
yeah I mean if you've watched the
trailers you you already know and are
even playing a little bit of ground
zeroes you know most of the people that
are in this game they're gonna be your
antagonists right like skull face we
already know skull face we already know
I guess spoilers what you've seen in the
trailers and everything else Burning Man
yeah who looks to be psycho sometimes on
in about three days it's like they are
the bad guys they are the crew that's
out to get me or whatever and there's
only like one or two instances where
it's really like alright I'm in a boss
battle yeah and even those aren't like
they were before there's there's nothing
like the sorrow there's nothing like the
end there's no beauty in the beast
school no there's no revolver ocelot you
know a middle gear one battle no man
made of bees Oh rollerblading bomb
disposal expert crap about fat man every
loved fat or fat man I want fat man's
prequel story sure if that's not in five
that's all I want my money back
afterwards yeah Kojima Productions
around DLC he'll be the spin-off yeah
yeah that'll be the next video game I'll
be Batman Ladyhawke style game they've
done it before
yeah substance on the system's Xbox oh
right
sorry sorry Internet down so phantom
pain yeah let's talk a little bit about
it great um what's the nearest
touchstone for like a different another
game like a similar game does it feel
like cuz I'm looking at it it seems like
ok bass invasion kind of a loud cry 3
feel like in that's a great how does it
hasn't ranked up against for like then
yeah that's the thing is you said
there's stark differences between the
last metal gear and this metal gate
right yeah I mean this is I mean a
better game than for it's a better story
it's better gameplay it's this left
before Tim and I always talk about right
then for got a 10 at IGN I was second
opinion and I'm like this game is great
and then the rest of my career there I
was like don't put it on a top 25 list
right like I don't think this is not a
game I would recommend to anyone right
like that's not a game that if you don't
know anyone metal gear jump into yeah
for four I think is out of four and two
or maybe a little less so game or is the
ones you can't just jump into and
understand what's happening right right
if it is very story based and it is very
linear and it's very based on what had
come before it right from one two and
three but didn't oh there's this one
still have a cinematic feel to it or is
it much more about yeah I mean it does
like it's a different thing I feel like
they've gone from cinematic feel to
television feel like they call like like
reality show like real house why I know
you know it's it's not even real Hannah
to be amazing
it's episode two it's episode three got
art ok credits roll in the beginning it
tell it it tells you as soon as you're
coming in on your helicopter who's gonna
be in that oh really you don't even get
surprised if the skulls show up or if
Burning Man shows up right it says like
guest starring and it will put their
name you like oh I guess so guys are
gonna show by the end of this episode
then they do
yeah it's trying to be how many hours
have you played for it
I've how many hours today now to beat it
or to have that played so far okay first
of all to beat it I rolled credits on
the main story 30 hours in okay now then
there of course there's a bunch of other
missions that will remain nameless that
then are you know reveal the truth and
answer questions about this guy and do
all you know I mean like the truth yes I
bet it doesn't I bet it has it like
elevates twice as many new question
here's more questions next time knock it
answer those
on the class middle gear solid two to
three way yeah Danny Danny I've been on
your question there was a great question
what is there another is there what is
the closest approximation of this what's
the book like what's a good analog for
this game I think this game is a mixture
of things it is metal gear it's peace
walker for sure it is it is HD peace
walker it's peace walker blown out with
no because I mean think about peace
Walker was you jump in and the maps were
small then there be loading screens
connecting them all obviously that's
gone but that's the same gameplay-wise
of getting out there doing it but
there's a big dash of farcry assassin's
creed in there of all right cool like
I'm gonna go out and I need to do this
I'm gonna do this mission I've decided
to do this side mission I'll go do it's
simple I want to extract this P o W the
closest hello hello you know copter drop
point is a thousand meters away no big
deal they drop you there and you're
going and then it's like oh crap there's
an animal over there I don't think I've
captured him yet so you go you tag them
exu Fulton him out you take him home
yeah put them in the zoo back home then
you come across an outpost you're like
you see do you see my confusion jumping
into this game why ain't there insu why
not seem so you've been hired on another
mission by the NGO Renee at any point
explain that when you're kidnapping
people how you get them to actually work
for you in a productive manner a boss
kinda kidnap Kevin he hasn't done
anything more stuck on a platform what
are they gonna do so they have to work
yeah alright you date you toss people in
the brig and you have to convince them
not you but somebody's convincing that I
won't work for you well another guy that
you folsom in the air is convincing them
so you you've enslaved a bunch of people
and gotten the lead slave is like I'm
gonna take everyone else out and make
them productive for you how do I do that
with Kevin I don't know so far all he
does is just break out all machines yeah
that's how we did it but there for a
nanomachine yeah yeah but no it's got
all those things because it is like
though then there's this new outpost you
capture it you get the emblem for it you
know you are going and I'm the amount of
times I'm like I've already captured
that outpost I don't have to worry about
it but I tagged all the guys so I know
where they are and then it's revealed
that one of them is an A+ it combat Oh
Mike well now I got to capture that guy
and I might as well capture all of his
friends too and ring
like they're in the same softball team
together exactly I could it's like when
you see two really cute kittens brother
and sister yeah gotta take em home gotta
eat them both yeah but it begs the
question it's like the old Woody Allen
saying like why would you want these
people as part of the team they are so
easily captured I'm not getting captured
no yeah I put a balloon around my head
firing me up into the sky mother hen
you're when you bring right around my
neck no good you're bringing him home
and you're training them that's the
whole thing you got it play pokemon like
Kevin Kevin right ringing ammo and then
trading it at gentlemen thank you so
much for coming on state talk with Metal
Gear Solid 5 fix your headband obtain a
Konami guy who's stuck in traffic just
don't worry about it
don't worry don't worry about a man in a
inning it's a bad plug I'm sorry all
right 36 minutes a new let's play will
be up on youtube.com slash kinda funny
games 35 too funny comm noon what are
you guys doing for the rest of the week
right you got we've done an entire week
now we'll do an entire week next week
next week let's plays and with the very
first mission of Metal Gear Solid 5
because it's so spoilery but that's
talking about it and debating it okay as
if it won't already be ruined by then by
everyone knowing while wearing toilet
paper my all put on the paper mask and
do that awesome and thanks so much
when's your meet and greet as well you
do wonder you this tomorrow after you
lobby yes perfect so we're here at PAX
we have a panel tonight 9:00 p.m. come
hang out with us today food and
everything well not at the mean or not
at the pale tonight tomorrow we're going
to go to the lobby with you at 4 o'clock
over at the comedy club and then right
afterwards a meet greet and booze and
such sounds good parlor live if you're
in Seattle are the live Seattle
gentlemen thanks so much coming on
appreciate it thank you how's that
pleasure and yeah we'll be back in at
just a couple minutes got a bunch more
cool [ __ ] coming up and law breakers
Cliff Bleszinski is gonna be on its own
Randy Pitchford is coming on I want to
ask him about that new Borderlands movie
Oh lives today
yeah we'll be back in a second with our
city skylines stay too and make sure you
hit that Add button and we'd be back in
a second right here on YouTube gaming at
PAX Prime
thank you that one venture over there
never claps oh no she slap it